madison thank you a fundraiser was held  today to remember members of our local  police force who lost their lives to  covet 19.  the event put on by the injured police  officers fund honored metro lieutenant  eric lloyd  who died last july an officer jason  swanger who died of covid complications  last month  swinger's sisters spoke today about the  importance of community support  we couldn't do this without them without  the help of ipof  metropolitan police department so  anytime the community can come out and  give to a family  who's lost you know their loved one in  this way this is amazing  and helpful all proceeds from today's  event go to help families of injured and  fallen officers